So when you're looking for a web API,
it's a lot like looking for
any other framework that you
might bring into your code.
You want to see if it's well supported,
when was it last updated.
If it's a GitHub project,
you can see when the last commit was.
If there's people that are making pull
requests, if it's actively used by other
developers, all these things would be
great signs that this API outside of
what it's functionally
doing is a good call.
And then you want to make sure of course
that it can do what you need it to do.
And testing around with it, playing
with it, you could play with a couple
different options and find one that
works, and that's how I choose web APIs.
That's the same way that
I choose frameworks.
>> So for finding and
vetting libraries, I tend to
first go to the Apple libraries.
They tend to be much
better documented and
more highly optimized for the hardware
that you're working on in iOS.
One of the libraries that
I first investigated for
a video player app was
the MPMoviePlayerController,
which is a simple implementation of
a view controller for playing a video.
It's very quick and
easy to get up and running, but
it doesn't really provide anything else.
I wanted more features that I could add.
I wanted a new interface.
I wanted to be able to play
with the video even more.
So I looked even further, and
Apple provides the AVFoundation library,
which allows audio, video,
audio-synthesizing, video effects,
all these different tools that
MPMoviePlayerControllers don't provide.
And they allow you to create
a much more rich user experience for
the people using your app.
I used this on an app at
a previous company, and
it allowed us to create this user
interface that was unique to our app,
that you can't find anywhere else.